so i got a call from my good friend york
newman the head of microsoft flight
simulator he told me it was imperative
that i meet with him so i'm in this
helicopter we're flying to this location
we're on our way let's go
[Music]
york hey paris good to see you good to
see you thanks for coming to this team
no thank you what am i doing here later
let's get in we don't have much time oh
okay
all right first right across the atomic
that's where our contact is we headed
towards arlington it's still secret
i'm sorry
york
what is this place oh you'll see let's
go
[Music]
wow look at this place
nick how's it going hello
paris i would like to introduce nick
partridge from the smithsonian national
and space museum thank you for having me
but this makes a lot of sense i saw
during the trailer there was a
collaboration between the smithsonian
national air and space museum and flight
simulator here we are at the national
air space museum so let's talk about
that collaboration tell me more about
that well york and i have been talking
for more than a year he was looking for
me and it turns out i was looking for
him to ask the same question which was
don't you think that our our
organizations have a lot in common
dedicated to bringing flight to everyone
and uh
i was looking for the spirit of san luis
which is in the smithsonian ever since
1928 and the smithsonian was gracious
enough that gave us a millimeter perfect
scan which is what will feature in the
40th anniversary edition but as nick and
i kept talking it was very clear you
know the world's foremost museum for air
and space the smithsonian
and microsoft celebrating its 40th
anniversary it's a match made in heaven
and there's lots of things we can do
yeah authenticity accuracy access it's
all there we're hoping that if everyone
has as much fun in the community with
the content that we initially
collaborated on a couple of our most
historic aircraft and some of the other
aircraft in this center are already in
the simulator maybe we can jump in with
both feet and do more in the years to
come maybe even who knows we'll go crazy
we'll put the space shuttle in there
[Music]
oh that sounds
amazing all right you guys have never
been here before this is my first time
all right so uh keep your eyes peeled
stick stick together and uh york i've
got something special for you right
around here perfect
check this out this is my favorite plane
the youngest u52 3 motor amazing and
that that is an awesome plane and as i
look at all these planes around here it
makes me ask the question
are you going to put all of them in
flight tim maybe not all of them but we
hope a lot of them in the 40th
anniversary that comes out this fall we
already have three we have the right
flyer the spirit of saint louis and the
dc3 and we hope to get a few more as
nick and i were talking there's a lot of
things we could do yeah we started with
the most iconic ones and uh who knows
there's no lack of opportunity
you know i keep saying amazing because
this place is amazing and just like
flight sim it just keeps going so what
else is happening it does seem like
we're going supersonic like the concord
here we've been doing a major update
ever since we launched every month since
august 2020 and just today we're
actually launching world update 10 and
guess what tell me it's the united
states and it's huge we have a dozen
cities a new height field brand new
aerials new missions new airports new
everything and as always
it's free and
check out this beauty this is the
beechcraft model 18 they call it the
twin beach it's a famous plane and
that's also launching today and it's a
great coincidence it's actually a huge
coincidence york's been working on that
beachcraft since before we met but it's
a great example of how much we already
had in common
so jorg what can we expect the rest of
the year from flightsim we have a ton of
great things coming up so today is world
update 10 we have two more world updates
one in august and one in october and
then in november we have the big 40th
anniversary edition which will be an
absolute delight for anyone who loves
aviation okay that 40th anniversary
edition tell me more about that yeah so
we're celebrating by bringing back some
of the the planes from the old sims like
from platinum 10 9 8 even before that
and we're restoring some of the old
missions and we're bringing back some of
the airports that were in those editions
so it's a real celebration of the
franchise so this celebration is not
only of the franchise but the past as
well and we're also adding brand new
things on top of it like that the
community really wanted for example
helicopters my soba wrote a brand new
fluid dynamic system to make all that
work and we're adding gliders which is a
completely different way to experience
the planet it's just you and the wind
and then the last one is we bringing
what's the biggest deal for simmers a
brand new wheel to life airliner the
a310 from airbus yeah by a brand new
partner called indie builds a great
development team in fact of the 10
planes we're bringing most of them are
created in collaboration with third
parties so it's a really cool way for us
to integrate with the creator community
now
how do i get this if you're on game pass
if you already own flight sim the 40th
anniversary edition is a free upgrade
this has just been an incredible
experience seeing all these planes and
going through the history and everything
that's coming to flight simulator thank
you so much thanks for coming to dc
paris thank you nick for the great
collaboration with the smithsonian and
for kicking off the 40th anniversary
edition of flyson it's been wonderful
thank you so much thank you
[Music]
today was a good day
but now
i have a need for speed
[Music]
i'm headed to the danger zone baby
[Music]